greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
hymns sixty-six percent of men lose
their hair by the age of 35 the thing is
when you start to notice hair loss it's
too late for him is calm is a one-stop
shop for hair loss skin care and sexual
wellness for men thanks to science
baldness could be optional and connects
you with real doctors and medical degree
solutions to treat hair loss with
well-known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescriptions to help you
keep your hair now what I'm gonna do is
this for the church family you can order
right now our listeners will get them a
trial month or ends for five hours today
right now while supplies last see the
website for full details this will cost
you hundreds if you went to a doctor or
a pharmacy so go to forums comm slash
Joey that's for hims comm slash Joey
another sponsor I like to welcome to the
show is 23andme now to December 25th
which is Christmas Day the 23andme DNA
kits are on sale 23andme helps you
understand what your DNA can tell you
about you and your family story it's
named for the 23 pairs of chromosomes
that make up your DNA explore the
genetics behind your appearance and
senses so now to December 25th get 30%
off any 23andme kit order your DNA kit
at 23andme comm slash Church that's
23andme comm slash church again that's
23andme dr. Nam slash church check this
[ __ ] melee mic Dulce woman will
make you move back to Jersey the beach
man gotta be at the beach gotta be near
the water and want to want to raise my
kids the way I grew up
great to see you good to see you - it
blew my mind tonight when you said you'd
move back to Jersey you know you left
the whole Vegas scene you left it behind
and moved on that's it that's it man you
know Vegas was I love Vegas you had a
great time in Vegas how are you in Vegas
four years
you know and still have still have you
know reach and they get still have a
couple things over there but east coast
now that's the that's the home base
that's HQ that's the set up very happy
happy to be back you're diggin it is
your first winter back first winter I'm
pomp man pumped I'm gonna [ __ ] shovel
and shovel
everybody's walkways you know like that
type of energy you know how many wonders
do you think you're gonna do that for
one if I get a snow blower next would
you have girls I have two little girls
two daughters hold the three and a half
and just turned two oh yeah that thing
what a huge man come on get him home
ice-skating on real
you know father laced yeah I have a go -
I hate dirty [ __ ] song thing this
morning at the school assembly the
[ __ ] line was like studio 54 so I
want him to read her the book first for
the first half hour when them my wife
will even snag the chair gonna have to
sit there - for grades Mike with my life
because you're awesome does she need to
do this [ __ ] this is what it's all about
sales when it's about and I had [ __ ] to
do and the whole thing like you know
what I think I should yeah I really have
that's what you have to do that's it
what's better than that and you always
think haha maybe I'm not doing good as a
dad you know maybe I'm not doing it
right or whatever yeah and that's why I
trying to go to all those things so that
I didn't feel too good I'm like you know
what I'm not gonna go [ __ ] with Thai
class okay and I'm going I don't have a
great time you know I try to always go
to something yeah and that's great to
see when a guy like you finally goes you
know what my Korea can go to this place
in this place you know what out of
respect of my family I want to go back
to the roots you know you know I think
about all the time I just got no roots
left yeah all the new jersey where I
came from holiday you know I see the
traffic here yeah man traffic in
northern New Jersey headed by Lincoln
Tunnel that's why I'm from are you
[ __ ] crazy it's so much better though
i sat in traffic on the Turnpike leaving
the airport it was so much better than
LA traffic it was because it was cold
and it was dark you know it was grainy
it was it was beautiful I really enjoyed
it you flying to new look you get off
you drive ten minutes also you smell
it's not you smelling the airport man
smell [ __ ] oils and [ __ ]
in now you just fire someone that I
would drive you smell so many different
[ __ ] odors now and you know like you
said I never knew Delaware was the
cancer capitol the country yeah it's
always ranked very highly not to bash on
Delaware but that was absolutely
surprised that doesn't surprise me
man as everything goes down and yeah the
way it sticks out a little bit so it
probably just gets caught there all the
Maluku lotta [ __ ] Delaware Thank You
Barry that's crazy but now man that's
great that you took your famiiy yeah you
know I got a couple things cooking
obviously sit down and say to myself
what do I really want to do yeah you
know well you know right now what you
really want to do you know we all I
think you all carry that zinnia right
you know it's it's the pointing you in
that direction anyway you know know
there's some things you have to do well
you have to work yeah maybe you know you
want to stay as relevant you can you
want to keep doing the bike there's a
lot of things you need to do yeah I like
going on the road yeah but I also like
staying at home you know I would love
for a show to get picked up but whatever
but I know I've been here for 20 years
and I know how many stars have to be
aligned just perfectly for your show
funny things to ever get picked up so I
don't really put sweat into it so I've
seen people walk around here with gloves
and smack people in the face I think
people get deals lives chains and also
nothing happened and now you gotta eat
[ __ ] from these guys cuz you're acting
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know you
act like a [ __ ] [ __ ] for eight
months while your show is getting
developed then that work didn't pick it
up now you gotta walk in from the same
oh it's John so you better be good for
the people on the way up because you're
gonna see the same [ __ ] on the
way dancing show that's at you know my
world is just not petunia I gotta hide
my D I sold it if they do it they do it
c'est la vie yeah I already know the
[ __ ] drill because that means I gotta
go to work yeah let me go to work out
what you asked for right and that's Fox
work that's twelve hour days it's a
multi can yeah yeah it's the whole thing
but it's work yeah
it's work also you start
to the airport man I'm this lax fox
every day and eat this food you know you
don't look at things for what they are
yeah so I'm just waiting to hear or
whatever and then I have to decide she's
five yeah you know I don't know I just
don't know take it every day
this is it this has been one of these
things where the ride has been crazy I
could see myself moving back to Jersey
yeah a lot of ways I can't
I don't dare get do the winters happen
when was the last time you were there
November 8th and where'd you stay
northern New Jersey it's gonna hell
isn't it no I stay in the hotel hotel I
take the ferry into the city yeah I
worked I worked the city yeah but I stay
in the northern New Jersey sighs it's
easier for me sure I get to see my
buddies I go to the cemetery I go to all
my spots my Chinese yeah my Rudy's clam
bar I get to go to [ __ ] and get a Cuban
plate and it's done I don't have to wake
up in the sea and drop $40 for a cheese
omelet yeah and a cool you know I just
New York is too much for me now at this
age yeah it's too fast for me
so it is it is fast I'm just thinking
about getting you down I want to get you
down as sure it's a 45-minute train ride
hop right on long rides pop right up
you're right and some would say is Penn
Station when and I keep saying marburo
during route 34 35 or as gorgeous that
also the friend lived there whenever I
would do calmly I would stay there and I
I remember driving the angle and this is
the perfect [ __ ] location yeah you're
close enough to the slopes like I'm
still in the suburbs said he had you
ready for this he had a drive through
Carvel what not even a mile from this
house that's been named so I would get
high and I tell him listen I gotta go
for a ride it's not a squad your pilot
you want to know why I was following a
parent
Drive Thru car they drive you Carvel
that was entrapment that right amazed I
should be only I used to get a double
cone and a chocolate shake oh don't eat
the cone and then string a shake on the
way up like I only went and got a shake
yeah but I would get a car my favorite I
like our girls a double cone but on the
chocolate college sprinkles with whipped
cream how many times have you made that
order
that was too smooth [ __ ] ten million
ten million times I bet I was a Carvel
kid never go to carve out there was a
point in my life never cookie puss no I
wasn't cookie puss guy that was that no
I [ __ ] that I never ate that because
it was weird as [ __ ] what was cookie
puss it wasn't that the car Bell thing
it was like the always on TV like the
cakes right yeah commercial my weird hi
how are you this is Tom Carvel telling
you that we have cakes for all occasions
that's how it was all right yeah having
WPIX in the pictures just pop up of Tom
Carvel
yeah but that was a car gar on 39th and
Bergen way next to a bar called listen
to me this is how much I love this place
I thought all the bottom of the barrel
if you read the book good fella yeah the
movie the book - the movie
that's what hang out bottom of the
barrel and upstairs is Fuji pie kung fu
the guy is still there food job I
account for the guy 70 then he still
teaches food job pie from the second
floor
how about that but that Carvel on the
corner we would walk up that hill first
of all I come from the second aliased
place in the country where North Bergen
New Jersey a right before Lincoln Tunnel
he park your cars is the second ileus so
if you walked up the hill you burnt
those cabins yeah Carvel was a [ __ ] yeah
all right you need to carve Allen if you
walk up to Cemetery Hill and let the
project hell you're good you deserve
that Carver well isn't that what a
double cone is it's like a tea or
something I like it's one calm but - yes
you have chocolate picture two scoops
fresh with whipped cream and colored
sprinkles and I would drive the truck
like this look we've eaten the ice cream
[ __ ] laughter like taking a sip from the
chocolate shake and [ __ ] oh and you
can just go right to sleep afterwards oh
[ __ ] yeah at night with a joint as a
coma
that wasn't sleep I grew up on that [ __ ]
a karlão shake nice and thin chuckling I
love [ __ ] what what do you think when
you hear like fat guys talking about
stuff they eat like have you eaten that
much ice cream in like he know these
dudes yeah not bad
and [ __ ] you hate pie at the diner
with a string of hair on it like give a
[ __ ] expected at least one hair on
somebody's where oh good lord
[ __ ] yeah french fry crinkled hair a
little [ __ ] little busboy oh dear you
give me [ __ ] about where I eat tacos up
god damn it there's hair in your food
what was the others South Jersey ice
cream spot there's one that wears
Hoffman's Hoffman's is big
Hoffman's but there's another one that
day that's an ice cream place and then
there was another place where I went to
that you went in there like it's kids
you know like in Jersey this could only
happen in Jersey yeah
Lee you're gonna die if you went in
there like we were going to play
basketball something yeah as like a team
and the coach would take you there if
you win but there was always that thing
that if you hate it you got it for free
but if you didn't need it cause you're
like $80 yeah yeah like the challenge
take those eyes I had one of those
friends one day that got really high and
right in front of me he's like I'm
ordering the boat no my dog you're not
gonna eat he's a dog he ate three
corners inside perfect
it was like Kido overload it was whipped
cream 300 cherries Oh like that type of
Schilling was it really carries zombies
a Jew ate like 20 cherries a container
whipped cream like I still remember the
nuts yeah how many scoops I forget what
the scoops were I was like a really big
bowl yeah it was like a [ __ ] who you
guys you couldn't even like only an
[ __ ] with raised his hand yeah and
he's like and it was a ripoff it was
really like $8 an ice cream sure but if
you [ __ ] hate it then we give it to
you for free is good it really was like
48 77 78 79 15 bucks
$15 there's a lot of [ __ ] money I
know a lot of money pay $15 when it was
like 20 maraschino cherries mmm it was
20 can of whipped cream dang of nuts you
know [ __ ] and beat this guy went in
there one day we were high
well you said let's do it and I'm like
I'm not [ __ ] he I knew it that like I
don't like ice cream that much yeah I
liked ice cream a little limit not your
double-fist in a milkshake walk yeah
everyone has their limit is those there
are levels of this you know people
talking about the Dolce diet let's talk
about the New Jersey diet
yeah cuz I grew up on a [ __ ]
buttered roll and a can of coke yeah the
[ __ ] does that do to your body don't
[ __ ] up a buttered roll a kaiser roll a
kinds of buttered roll which just things
sugar just instead of like it being a
roll just picture like a maybe a couple
teaspoons of sugar it's all sugar it's
all sugar a kaiser roll is all sugar
salt sugar very little if no fiber at
all in a bunch of synthetic chemicals
just mixed in there but then one of the
most disgusting New Jersey saying so you
had a can of Kuwait's back up a saying
you got a can of coke with the with the
guys we think with the scoops of sugar
[ __ ] yeah what do you have for breakfast
like I have 1/2 1/2 a cup of oats 1 cup
of berries 2 tablespoons of chia seeds 2
tablespoons of hemp seeds a sprinkle of
cinnamon almond butter or peanut butter
depends on the day sometimes I'll do
like a steel cut oats and make love to
it on the mist over top sometimes it's
Oprah and just with the kettle pour it
on top and out the door but that's
that's almost my everyday
no eggs um eggs I'll usually do second
or third meal you know so like I have
eggs pretty much every day two to four
whole eggs and you know 2 to 4 yolks
let's say like let's say four days a
week
but that's using the second meal a lot
of lot of vegetables you know so I make
like omelets and frittatas and quiches
and just like
poached eggs and like sautéed veggies or
like as a cold salad do a lot of
different things with that that's
typically my my second meal like my 11
o'clock or so meal not too I'm counting
the hours like a bodybuilder I'm [ __ ]
hungry again you know car needs gas boom
let's let's hit and keep it going you
know there may be like a piece of fish
or something a little bit later and then
dinner time might be like a chili or or
a pasta we're like a stir-fry or like
sushi even the wife may like a possible
to it oh [ __ ] [ __ ] tremendous is my
3.2 cup
okay three point three points a wedding
watches what's the points explain the
points to make the points is 42
I get 39 points a day okay to consume to
consume okay eggs are free okay you can
means that we want chicken breast free
okay okay so I'll [ __ ] go in the
backyard and throw three grilled chicken
breasts on yeah then I get white rice
and black beans Cuban stop I'm fine
that's nine points because beans are
free beans and from all you pay for is
the rice or I'll put a cup and a half of
rice and put nine points and I could eat
the beans your game in the sense that
again aren't you
who gives a [ __ ] listen I the reason why
all those diets because I'm honest with
you yeah like how heads you're bowing
I read your book three times you have
four dishes actually the other ones
don't you come close to me we can't talk
quick qingyao don't even come baby kima
I think I don't like honey yeah I like
your chili yeah there's one thing I
didn't like them - chili I like your the
spaghetti you making out spaghetti I'll
stay a pass on Sam
but the quinoa there's a lot of [ __ ] I'm
going to tell you already among me I
would have a life what about like
stir-fry like salmon and rice and veg
top down no brown rice in my world no
I'm never gonna have nor mine white rice
you only thank you no disrespect today I
can't I can't I do have a problem lately
that you're not gonna [ __ ] believe oh
I got the [ __ ] Italian thing and I've
been talking with different Italian
people and they all tell me like a month
in San Sebastian one night and then
throw Sebastian I go Sebastian you
believe at this age I can't eat cheese
though I had a problem with my stomach
for three or four months huh didn't know
what it was horrible farts yeah thought
I had cancer you know I saw it cheap
jobs
George st. Pierre doing into yarn Rogan
I'm like if he's got cancer [ __ ] do
you mind if I - Christ and I and I got
scared and I realized that I went to the
doctor and I started taking things away
it took away the edibles for a while
yeah and still my stomach was bothering
me and I had that coconut flavor what
was the thing I got you oh the
was protein well yeah it was a protein
drink it was a vote car something
kitchen uh it was low carb coconut
vanilla you know is Elissa I was making
that with milk in the morning coconut
with coconut milk and something was it
wasn't something was messing with me and
then my wife started getting I don't
know I don't know where my wife doesn't
know much around balls from gyal sit
stand what whoops without since your
daughter loved us no now she don't even
[ __ ] she looks likes me
gotcha yeah you eat it like a bowl I
scream like what's it all balls
yeah like I don't need it all year when
I'm in yeah when I go home like the
second or third day I go to this little
deli nobody even sees me over there oh
my god czo and I got the pre-shoot with
roasted peppers [ __ ] and went once
yeah and I'm good here what a week if
I'm back in Jersey
oh ok back in jail so he's back in
Jersey that would eat one a week maybe
one - no there's no no there's no yeah
but now I can't I so I finally took the
mutts out of my life and I was like huh
don't watch was [ __ ] killing me about
that so I started talking to more people
and then my buddy told me he's a talent
he goes thought I had to stop when I was
50 god no more pizza and then another
friend of mine then Sebastian came they
got it with sauce okay that he got the
Italian thing that sauce now you know
it's it's a Sidney
I wonder so let's go deeper into the
issue what is the issue the issues it's
a digestive issue more than anything but
why is the body no longer able to break
down the cheese is that what it is where
is there something mechanical going on
possibly in the body maybe your stomach
lining is worn out maybe there's an
ulcer of sorts maybe it's a hey little
hernia possibly where the stomach kind
of sticks through the top of the
diaphragm it could just be the kind of
deluded or diminished or hindered the
enzymes necessary to help break down the
dairy you know maybe those are just you
know two powerless
I've never liked milk first I don't like
milk drinking it I don't like drinking
about chocolate milk
you you who are you it's water shut the
[ __ ] up
yeah sorry boss you don't know about the
you okay I mean you would just shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and egg creams I love
all that you who's a great yeah
chocolate milk ahead quick when I was a
kid yeah dead strawberry Quik came out I
can live with that for a while never
really was my fancy about the Hershey
syrup now Oh master burns
yeah that's tremendous I still need it
with milk a little club soda okay that's
the only way I could have a whole
[ __ ] half and a half of the old days
par don't give a [ __ ] yeah
when I was looking I was doing [ __ ]
behind the neck press walk
I'm gonna head half and half and I would
sit down with a container a half and a
half
I think of Hershey's and two bottles of
club soda yeah I just keep [ __ ]
staring and [ __ ] at night and watch TV
and stay up all night on that [ __ ]
show up but making gains right yeah [ __ ]
to me that age again doing that [ __ ] I
used to pace that my old Dolce Chase
when I was 18 what was it me and my
buddies were doing this five sets of six
power lifting they're done love it we
would [ __ ] get whole milk 16 ounces
half a [ __ ] pink ice cream week germ
tour three four because the barbarian
brothers were of course Marian brothers
said that they'd 36 eggs every day yeah
that was our goal to eat 36 eggs every
day so every day we'd make protein
shakes with like 15 eggs in there it
cooked or not cooked
oh [ __ ] rocky that's why you can't
digest dairy now [ __ ] disgusting Ron
nobody got big right only a barbarian
blows I thought they were eating decade'
Robin like the style balls eating out of
style so I used to put the thing in it
and we used to do five sit to six and
run and the whole thing and I believed
and that's when Joe Weider yeah only had
egg protein that's it yeah that's it
there was nobody else competing with Joe
Weider yeah you want to lose weight you
had to take the high nos at walk low
line mix yeah I forgot hip - I know
that's why people lost weight on cocaine
cuz you cut cocaine when I'm not at all
yeah so people started losing weight
going cocaine makes you lose weight no
it's the agnostic
it's not with it you [ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
cuz you're probably doing a grand - all
have you [ __ ] shall we be Brad the
[ __ ] 80s inox at all Mikey roof yeah
but you can find with slow line and I
inositol but since I announced at always
uses a good cocaine cut huh you couldn't
[ __ ] buy it would cost you go into a
how food store there's gonna be like $30
so we'd steal the capsules ok I'd steal
the capsules cuz they were already wait
for you see you guys [ __ ] go into the
city you give me the money to go inside
I can just draw a capsule in there scoop
a capsule out and nobody knows nothin
everybody's happy you follow me well
[ __ ] think you're dealing with Liam
Joey but an evil genius
[Laughter]
so was the rest of your Jersey diet
when I was a kid he sang about this
Porto Rican kiss there but Papa tourists
cool as [ __ ]
I loved little old me no he wasn't he
was in now why Air Force Base no
soldiers yeah older than me my a train
adventure sure and I there was be night
when he come up I'd stay by his half his
brothers and we'd watch TV lately but
the reason I like staying there cos in
the morning if you took a five block
walk you went from Bordeaux region Ville
it's Italian though right in the corner
22nd at 21st is central was a guy that
made a little Italian old man and he
made that Italian bread that's like this
real [ __ ] long yeah like this long
real skinny yeah I would take two of
those the bag of zeppoles and I would
get a bar a hotel bar but [ __ ]
16-ounce coca-cola and that's what I
would eat for breakfast I would sit
there with the fresh bread and just a
stick of butter
yeah and just eat the fresh bread with
the butter and then the bag is that
please for the walk to school with
powdered sugar on it
diabetes take somewhere in your future
you're right
the thing I miss a lot from Jersey is
fried on muffins right I love when you
go into a [ __ ] diner and you can just
get a fried muffin they put butter on
and put
my grill yes they do yes they do
let's go to Jersey right now no my
friend told me that and asleep it was
the best thing ever happened we he did
it with a blueberry muffin though oh he
went at the top off put it in the
toaster oven put butter on it
oh I never heard about on an oil oh my
god listen my ex-wife and killer times
in house my ex-wife that [ __ ] could
make a muffin though that [ __ ] could
make a blueberry muffin just old school
from Buffalo box
she used to make fresh blueberry muffins
fresh blueberries and then the top she'd
no butter
oh it's sugar two coats of it one coat
and the other cocktail Ralph's doesn't
know we're right through you'd [ __ ]
take a blaster that forgot about it
you'd be talking all day nineteen nose
blueberry [ __ ] [ __ ]
I guess I'll stab at ten times and help
but she could make a good blueberry
muffin duck Wow and then I got hooked on
anything ever cream cheese and jelly on
a [ __ ] kaiser roll yeah that's not
bad though
no Jesus Christ that's terrible you see
it's tasty right it's tasty I don't
think I've had that it's pure diabetes
though I haven't had that in 40 years
[ __ ] that I got a cord on my face about
six months cream cheese and jelly from a
hash ways where you know whether you who
you ever do cream cheese and peanut
butter
no that's discussed on a bagel oh that's
good that's great what does coke do to
you in the morning like when you how bad
hope for Cola yeah what about heroin
let's think of it is it that it's that
bad it's that bad it's that bad and it's
addicting to it has a powerful addiction
that we know of right it's crazy
well I stopped drinking coke I moved on
now thinking about giving it to Kate ten
years ago I think I stopped drinking
coke yep now I drink
it's been years since I drank Coke but I
know the last time I drank Coke I spit
it up it tastes like and then it just
went away
Diet Coke taste work and I have Coke
Zero at the house which I have from time
to time just to break the monotony it
may just to feel like I'm doing some bad
ones smoking reefer every the
ingredients that co0
yeah it's pure [ __ ] liver crushes
don't kill you remember
you know what the water you showed Rogen
in Jersey yeah but don't you know one
don't you
that's where they get here's the sad
thing it's true right now I don't test
eat I'm not even in the bath i bags on
in my yeah that's super jeans man don't
know if I've been look at you like I
don't like to take anymore
I don't like nothing sweet me more in my
mind I like cake but in the reality it
repulses me right I like I like you know
my cheetahs a two point jello sugarless
pudding that's my cheat I'm gonna call
the chocolates to fairway watch it will
you um from me you know what if I eat
two of them
nobody's gonna [ __ ] die is this a
whole pie no no up of jello okay it's
like I'm gonna see this point since cup
of jell-o okay the Trump of vanilla
pudding you know
so is it Weight Watchers it comes like
they say food no there's jello okay real
joke thing I like about Weight Watchers
I eat what I want they have a list of
all the restaurants on here uh-huh
it's like bang it up press right here I
open it up I got four points left for
the day okay all right I got 42 for the
week if I need to spend it okay then I
click on to here and then it does it's
not shown in here but I have your
activities gotcha so I got Muay Thai in
there so every time you weigh yourself
and you go in and said between minutes
and when we thought real pointy minutes
yep not [ __ ] you know like if I go to
an hour class and when we die I did 20
minutes of we die yeah the rest of time
you stand around he's teaching the
technique and whatever unless you do
with circuit trainings yeah so you can
put that all in there that's cool so
okay so chicken beans yeah fish you know
eggs free all free Sookie much as you
want gratis like you get up in the
morning now 20 years ago no when I came
from Cuba since I didn't know better I
eat scrambled eggs yeah no I can't have
a scrambled eggs if it was up to me Hank
I would eat four [ __ ] scrambled eggs
it's
with zero that's how you cheat on weight
watch for scrambled eggs salt and pepper
yeah that's it delicious but me I need
where I need we have Wonder Bread and he
took the bread Jesus pile of sugar I
need tonight is a wonder birthday get
the party started
but Wonder Bread is 2 points a slice
thank you 2 pieces of white bread you
actually they still make Wonder Bread
[ __ ] yeah they still make [ __ ] yeah I'm
hooked on Wonder Bread Jean in Fallon in
food stories wheat white is 2 points to
slice so for breakfast I have two eggs a
piece of boy said American cheese and
two pieces of [ __ ] white bread for
six points I love that Wonder Bread also
makes a healthier wheat verse yeah the
[ __ ] bacon a ji Brown I eliminated
the bacon from my diet yeah I'm not
going anywhere with bacon prosciutto
you're not going anywhere with that [ __ ]
on a weekly basis now I presume once in
a while a little like my wife told me
last night I bought sausage I don't want
any charge no more yeah I'm just not
interested in sauces no more after a
certain age I tell you what I don't like
either I don't like eating meat later
tonight yeah my meat intake has been cut
in half in the last year I mean cutting
in three quarters how much meat would
you even one sitting typically what
Robin was buying
caro-kann bought me more steaks than my
mother okay I would sit with him and get
a 16-ounce yeah baked potato yeah if you
eat that at four o'clock it's a big
difference than you eat done at nine
o'clock
yeah and there's a bigger difference of
you each other [ __ ] 11:30 you can go
up to your room like a lien those all
babysitting so this is a big difference
so he's normal life regular life I'll
try to eat meat early in the day and
then he fish for dinner yeah I've been
more being conscious yeah I'm CUBAN and
I love like the end I'll ever be yeah
and they say that people who eat beans
live longer now they're in the group 5
zone of people who eat beans and their
diet every day might not include rice
you know the rice might deactivate the
effects of the beans well yeah actually
right
wanting on the rice and bean kaibigan
yeah if I go to the Cuban place I'll get
rice and beans and pork chunks but I
won't get the fried yeah I won't get the
fried bananas yeah we'll get two cubed
soda I'll drink water you know this
little sacrifice right yeah you know how
much sone I drink that's your kid my
mother really there my mother had a bar
a bar a bar okay so you drank unlimited
soda from the age of four
from the from the draft from the top
from the taffetas she had the you had
the Puerto Rican labels which were like
lemon up okay they saw the 7up lemon up
nickname in the case yeah it was like
coke Cola root beer cream so she would
automatically tell the guy to load two
of the car every week she'd given extra
ten bucks yeah
so those two came to the thing there was
a time in my refrigerator where each
level was just sodas or beer when I was
growing up okay
the top level was he don't bail Cuban
iron beer the guy with the muscle you
know the second level was Coca Cola's
and the third level was just hanging
it's okay and the fourth level was like
vegetables or [ __ ] like that
but that's not always so does it yeah
huh like I always drink because she ran
a bar so we ran the bar accessible I
won't drink alcohol yeah but I'll drink
soda till the end the [ __ ] cash or
sure it wasn't sold
but what since I was 22 I went to it uh
my friend got a UH a half a DUI
it wasn't a full DUI I was like a half a
DUI he's a borderline
it was 83 or son now so he he a friend
of mine had done this for another friend
of mine whenever he needed money would
sit through seminars from so I told the
guy the guy come started when he want to
go to seminars I charged him 200 to go
to the seminar take the hit beat this
mic go check so I had to sit there from
8:00 to 5:00 yeah and what they show you
was the effects of alcohol when I was 19
I'll never forget that the guy was like
uh it was an anti DUI class and he said
this is the effects of alcohol when you
drink in the morning lunchtime and like
I was blown the [ __ ] away and then the
guy goes let me show you the
like some soda and he just went off and
I was sitting there like [ __ ] can I
drink 30 of those a day like in those
days I haven't even consider water water
wasn't even in my agenda
it's amazing you lived wasn't even in my
agenda right how many of those [ __ ]
iced teas did you drink out of the
[ __ ] container when you were a kid
only one
those are can't sighs tease those little
ones in the container yeah with a
missing [ __ ] [ __ ] all right the
little blue little barrels oh my god you
could taste the cardboard yep oh you
have no idea and our parents just
force-fed it to us they don't want us
around so what happens to the body when
you have a soda for breakfast there's a
whole cascade of events you know and
they'll express themselves differently
in each person you know not to avoid the
question I'll get to it but everybody's
gonna have a different response right do
the genetics due to your current state
of health and what else it might be
[ __ ] up with you right so it's all
gonna be a little different at the time
but the first big thing is just the the
rush of insulin which essentially is
insulin runs running through your body
and it's looking for it's looking for
good things good food to put where it
needs to go because the body's broken
down to [ __ ] up and [ __ ] up and needs
to repair and recover it needs
micronutrients and phytonutrients and
like yeah the the macro protein carbs
fats that's less essential and it goes
in and it finds just this disgusting
synthetic toxin essentially right and
now it's like well [ __ ] we got all this
where are we gonna put it like let's
just kind of put it everywhere let's put
it in the joint in the knee let's put it
in the artery let's put it in the heart
this is a very loose explanation of what
actually happens but this happens and it
happens in some way to everybody so the
more that you do that the more you're
signaling whatever genetic response that
you have to expedite the process and get
more focused on on this area and then
the addictive nature of soda which is
very addictive and sugar is very
addictive and synthetic sugars with
different ingredients become very very
addictive and some of the energy drinks
out there have caffeine so they're
doubling and tripling the addiction and
I'm not saying it's intentional but
factual that's that's actually happening
we know what the response is at these
compounds so people get stuck into that
like the sugar I so we'll go back to the
sugar and the the in my opinion from
where we're working where my team is
paying attention what that does more
than anything else it disrupts the
digestive environment therefore even
when you can then put good food in it's
not going to get digested and broken
down and absorbed and assimilated and
partitioned the way that it should it's
gonna be inferior simply because you're
a [ __ ] and ate the that had the soda
first thing in the morning you have all
the negative effects from drinking the
soda and then now you have to deal with
all the the backlog and the problems
because of the the first bomb that
dropped off you kind of broke the
infrastructure let's say big bomb goes
off boom that's a soda the whole
infrastructure is [ __ ] up in a town
the street lights don't work one of the
buildings is knocked down the [ __ ]
train track is crooked that's happening
in your body and I hope people get to
understand that because it's easy to
just point to other people well they're
fine they're fine well two out of three
people will die of lifestyle related
illness so they'll they're not fine
they're actually the two people next to
you are [ __ ] idiots so you have to
think a little bit smarter and what I
try and do is open up the factual side
just look at it as a fact we're not
gonna argue some [ __ ] scientific
study not that the studies are [ __ ]
but that's not the point
that's the smoke and mirrors really it's
all lifestyle it's all it's lifestyle
its your habits it's being accountable
and most people aren't accountable so
that goes back to that one soda so
drinking it soda every day it's not like
like ah this soda is really good for me
makes me feel awesome like I'm so happy
to be drinking this soda right now it's
like I'm gonna drink this [ __ ] soda
when I get that little that little hit
from it or whatever the addiction
endorphin serotonin and whatever the
response is you get that but then you
typically feel worse like lethargic and
I stomachs [ __ ] up and you get weird
movements and you know just everything
gets thrown off and then there's a
self-loathing like I'm the [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] like what am i dying I didn't
give a [ __ ] when I drank a soda for
breakfast you didn't know you did but
now if you did oh you had never drink a
soda for breakfast but some people do
and they haven't gotten to this version
yet of where you are no I wouldn't drink
the soda but you know you imagine so it
was like a big soda like in sitting in
front you like it's been filled like 10
years really since I drank soda about
the time I gave them coke the little hat
forward I went to Weight Watchers and I
still have a diet coke and that took a
while then so you transitioned off from
the the regular Cola by a little yeah
okay I just went off the coke - Diet
Coke knowing how bad that's even worse
for you yeah that's even worse for you
but letting my body adjust cuz I mean I
was throwing down yeah I seltzer water
helps a lot that was nice when I was
coming back from the comedy store and
I'd stop and get a container of New York
super fudge chunk Manhattan Jerry a
fudge chunk and a 32 ounce coke Jesus I
might take the cup gonna take half of it
and put it in the cup and pour the coke
over it and stir it and just drink soda
I would drink the full 32 ounce coke and
the whole container of Ben and Jerry's
New York super fudge shop that thought
that's on my way if he stopped to tie my
shoelaces for me okay
wow that was when they if I got home and
the elevator was broken I would have to
go somewhere cuz I was walking up the
steps not the fourth look like I
wouldn't go home okay they my waifu'
coin we were I I'm not coming home the
elevators broke what do you mean I'm not
walking for four I'd say a good Wow
I couldn't it was that bad one boy and
when I tell you about these eating
habits I had early on I was in
tremendous shame yeah cuz even when I
went to New York in 93 and I was no Mike
I was walking around that city now and I
still had a 34 36 waist I was still yeah
yeah it didn't I didn't put the weight
on to dirty sick so I moved all right
okay once I stopped everything I was
doing my whole lifestyle he founds in
New York you walk yeah there's one thing
you do I talked to Dean Dell ready
he says he's averaging 11 miles a day
Wow or something walking in New York
every [ __ ] day yeah you know that's
what he averages walking between comedy
clubs even big ones and watches I guess
I don't [ __ ] know 6 miles a day
alright when you eliminate that that
[ __ ] chakra system quick solutely and
you just delete the way you're eating
you know in 93 I walked when I belong to
a boxing gym and basically I wanted then
I hit the bag and they trained me once
in a while hunches on mitts but I just
use it as a locker yeah so I can have
clothes if I had to do comedy in the
city in midtown Manhattan nice run up
there workouts which and then go do
comedy I would just keep that locker in
midtown Manhattan was $38 a month
[ __ ] was and you gave a guy 20
unless you had the mitt for 20 minutes
20 bucks or 20 minutes that's all you
need 20 minutes on the mitts with a good
coach
finish on the bag you're done [ __ ]
crazy um which I've learned the last and
you don't really know you don't really
know you know no it's like I love people
with acai balls
yeah they killed themselves lovely it's
just and I didn't know this like I was
doing great on Weight Watchers and I
went back one week and I gained three
pounds I've looked over my menu yeah I
go what the [ __ ] am i doin at that time
I used to go to kickboxing and go to the
acai place and I'll get the chia seeds
with the goji berries with the bananas
the strawberries the [ __ ] granola
yeah and then I would eat that acai so I
thought I was eating fruit which is zero
yeah if you go home you can eat ten
bananas for breakfast too and you're
good that's insane
so I could eat ten bananas for breakfast
and I'm good sometimes if I gotta
stretch that day and I don't want to eat
between jiu-jitsu
you know how eat breakfast in two
bananas and I won't eat till 1:30 so I
come back from jujitsu and this is part
of the program
yeah Weight Watchers that's what you
want to do as long as you eat those 42
points they want you to eat those points
every [ __ ] day so you can you can eat
it in one meal or two meals or 10 meals
as long as you get this points and they
don't care
and there's free foods also like
bananas bananas but this was an
interesting point that when I went to
the council may go I mean this acai she
goes no those because when you drink
fruit and you bite fruit it's two
different stories so if you eat a banana
it's a zero a point yeah if I put a
banana in the milkshake it's eight
points hmm because it goes past your
saliva and which breaks down that sugar
and separates it yeah so it's weird I
was throwing a banana in my shake so I'm
like there's zero ya know then I thought
of that coconut milkshake I would put a
banana and then go I'm zero no so I had
to stop eating the acai bowls even
though I missed the [ __ ] yeah I would
just eat the top the fruit but even the
[ __ ] the goji berries they're [ __ ]
five points yeah for like two bounces
ago G berries the [ __ ] like that so all
that sweet stuff like I don't eat cake
nothing there's nothing in my house
nothing my weakness is the biggest
addiction that I had was peanut butter
okay that was my [ __ ] fro I love me I
love Hannah fighter ten stone to the
gills and coming home and first you get
it one spooled did you get another spoon
and like that then you get a third spoon
and then finally after about an hour
this 13 [ __ ] spoons in this thing
held it all with peanut butter on and
you got to wash it off instantly because
if you let it sit and then it smells
funny
yeah if you don't clean peanut butter
off you don't real quick and hit it the
next morning your sponges smell like
death two [ __ ] weeks everything it
really is true it's true I love [ __ ]
peanut butter but all that [ __ ] that I'm
telling you about was when I was that
was one of the reasons I knew I don't
know I think I died in these ghosts I
died of a heart attack because the you
know what we don't have here there's no
there's nothing Vida up to ten o'clock
here
yeah well this [ __ ] is Taco Bell right
this Carl's come out [ __ ] like that huh
could be yeah Danny is this nothing T
yeah you know in Jersey I got a place
that we go to one yeah but like when I
go home next week I'll go up 1011 look
at the seafood salad Italian seafood
salad with the common and the octopus
whereas there's the school Julia Trudy's
and it's zero
wait all this is the olive oil come on
now papa come on now he's some [ __ ]
column on not fried that sounds that's
right just a regular yeah okay like a
ceviche that I have yeah and they put
like the Italian things on I go in there
every night I don't touch the bread yeah
cuz they don't have no butter there so
why waste my time I'm a big olive oil
guy I believe that the reason yes aliens
live so long the olive oil just the
olive oil the red wine to an extent
after one extent all the old Italian
people I've seen live they all do the
same habit they they dip bread in olive
oil once a week yeah they switched the
turkey meatballs which kills Italians
yeah once they got a switch to turkey
meatballs that kills in the town that's
like that's like taking the Jews neck
brace you killed the tire once they
gotta make turkey meatballs that's the
end of an Italian yeah model it tastes
it tastes just the same no don't know it
don't die right leave me alone you gotta
put a piece of pork in the [ __ ] sauce
all right yeah leave me alone if we want
if you have a good sauce of Turkey thank
you I'm not big in turkey meat though
there was one girl I used to date the
Seattle that made a turkey burger and
you would jerk off all over the best
area and mushrooms are not get on a bun
oh my goodness I've never had done a
good turkey burger but every time I
think about of the turkey burger I throw
it away though
tastes like dick well compared to what
you were eating what like what was that
thing at the at the diner would be like
a cheeseburger with the steak fries with
the mozzarella you know how we do it so
those Jersey diners with the Greek
mother yeah you get the cheeseburger
deluxe yeah so you get a cheeseburger
with fries gravy mozzarella cheese on a
French disco fries just go for [ __ ] yeah
mozzarella and on the top of french
fries with gravy pour it on top with a
hold of [ __ ] open steak sandwich yeah
up to in the morning after a night of
[ __ ] be enough I would do a pork roll
and cheese omelet oh that would be my
thing with the disco fries oh Jesus
Christ
[ __ ] around here John there was a
place to [ __ ] him bark-bark filled dinos
on 69th Street not Birgit I'm Wednesday
night that cream a turkey and make your
[ __ ] sperm a sperm would come out of
your [ __ ]
turkey with the open steak sandwich with
the steak fries and then I got a
milkshake for dessert he went right home
coma doctor not you fall asleep with
your clothes on
it's like yeah the [ __ ] zanuck there
was always a fight this is one of my
chest but I always drew people out of
that and what nights you drew this
[ __ ] guy out right in front of us
then one night I almost see him get hit
by a car and then one day I found that
the guy died he left like eight million
dollars oh [ __ ]
to the waitress no the guy had like
there was this creepy guy who's dying
out at the diner yep
and he used to hang out at this bar from
time to time and then one day somebody
said you know guys like a coke sound
like how the guy was acting Harlow his
life and one day he died people say the
eight million dollars I don't know what
this got to do with a million had
anything had a billion dollars I knew
his brother son who the [ __ ] knows huh
the Brookshire diner there you go
cream a turkey soup oh I was never at
for about a year I got into the Taylor
ham and egg okay on a Portuguese roll
okay the Portuguese well that's way
before that Mamaluke roll that they they
would get well what's the big thing that
ties in wrong know that what's to do
what that they can't live without
pretzel no it tastes like dough it
tastes like eating [ __ ] dog potato
rolls
no the other one Hawaiian no Christmas
rolls whatever the [ __ ] they are awesome
mo sprays a new role that they use the
Tuesday everybody Millennials
ciabatta bread ciabatta bread that [ __ ]
haha
yeah that's not [ __ ] sorry that's
garbage
yeah that's garbage this is this is a
Portuguese role was like an Italian role
like an Italian bread but circular yeah
and it was like this big yeah I put a
[ __ ] hang on there with a piece of
[ __ ] Taylor ham and egg and a piece
of American cheese slice fin yeah stop
little gonna catch up a little bit salt
pepper
what a [ __ ] on but I would not be a
guide to dog yeah I'm a big opium
contract
Buono yeah yeah like all that stuff
that's the dance right Hartman
it's really weird how it's taking years
to stop with the baby that had gone off
the other book really helped a lot okay
that I think so bad [ __ ] you can't
stop you just can't stop yeah I thought
is not for bad situations inaudible [ __ ]
these little one people eating disorders
I mean it all I still remember several
rights of Pirate's Booty I had been one
night that in that fiery booty but then
the cheese puffs my wife bought off my
daughter for lunch and I went thinking
orange cheese puffs
those are [ __ ] and I found the bag
and I hate the whole like I like four
and then went on the Weight Watchers
thing and it was like four of them was
like three points I got it stopped it
and I found myself in the kitchen yes
the bag was empty those crumbs all over
me I can hear my wife in the morning
going Jesus Christ did you do lastly I
had made three or four sandwiches with
the cheese balls
what no quit them when I would get high
on those edible some nights yeah I had
to tell my wife to stop my coke stop I
would go home and make my sandwich then
another sandwich I sit there for an hour
and go and then once I went away once I
just started eating apples would you eat
anything with the sandwich like chips or
pretzels
no no chip guy or pretzel guy huh now I
eat an apple okay go hungry I hate a
banana now if I'm so hungry I need an
apple if I'm still hungry then eat the
[ __ ] sandwich get it off at least you
tried you die with the three apples at
least you know your [ __ ] the sandwich
out with no problem saying followed it
it's gonna come up nice and [ __ ]
smooth and the more than one no drama
might the right no drama
we call that the one wiper so Mike don't
you how you make a living
same same thing same just being still
gonna be a nutritionist yeah you know I
never was in a way because people asked
what do you do I'm like [ __ ] what do you
need I get it done you know it's it's
more like the fixer I come in I fix [ __ ]
what's going on your dies [ __ ] up your
blood works [ __ ] up your trainings
[ __ ] up your life is [ __ ] up what
your focus is [ __ ] up you know all
these different things that can be
[ __ ] up because I have the experience
of working at elite level for over 20
years with these high level performers I
can help fix it and yeah the nutrition
is everything that's the foundation so
we have nutrition is the foundation
stress management and rest that's number
two more important than then exercise
right exercises is probably the least
most important part of the entire
process so you make sure the nutrition
is sound and then you get any start to
tweak so what do I do that's what I do I
create content but we have online
training programs we have a team of
registered dietitians we do a lot of
work with the public we have four
best-selling books we have you know
these other you know things that we do
which is cool so the people that need
some health and fitness and weight loss
stuff we have it but my job my goal is
to share the information by any means
possible sitting here and talking to you
and then lay in the audience and then
having these conversations my job is an
educator more than anything else so it's
it's when I talk I try and share this
education this information based on the
experience that I've had the [ __ ] that
I've seen at the levels that I've been
apart and the teams that I've worked
with and the data that's come across my
desk so I just share this stuff I just
shared this is this is this is what I
say this is this is what happens and
this is what's gonna work this is what
has historically worked the vast
majority of time for the vast amount of
people so why don't let's just do this
stuff that stuff well yeah it worked
with twelve-year-old epileptics okay but
that's that's not you that's not this
that's you know not a bash Aikido but
that's kind of the concept and it's all
these different types of short-term like
we call them exclusionary fat diets you
will have short-term results six weeks
to 12 weeks let's say and then you kind
of crash and fall off and you make a
change yeah I gotta get back on instead
of just swinging the axe hitting singles
eat real food every two to three hours
based upon activity you know we don't
overeat because we eat again a little
while you drink water you avoid
synthetic chemicals toxins all right
let's not hurt let's not poison herself
anymore let's just drink real water eat
real food you know kind of throughout
the day how about how about we just kind
of do that and see what happens holy
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] leaner than I've ever
been I'm stronger than I've ever been
I'm [ __ ] sexier than I've ever been my
digestion feels better than it ever has
like
all this stuff happens and it's not
magic that's the way humans were meant
to live so it's what we suggest is is
just you know follow the same principles
that have sustained all life on the
planet since the dawn of time eat real
food and in great variety based upon
local geographic availability when it's
ripen in season all right so I could
think of hundreds of different recipes
out of just that batch of real food
right there without me in a ye little
[ __ ] about it I can't cook I can't go
to this the supermarket [ __ ] you that's
you're making an excuse now so we eat
real food
in wide variety so we get all these
different micro nutrients and
phytonutrients what actually is
important because we're cellular beings
we humans which works we're cellular we
have to think on a cellular level and
that's where the micro comes in the
micro nutrients of the phytonutrients
everyone focuses on the macros in the
high carb in the low carb that's so you
know so [ __ ] 1987 that's so like
small-minded when it comes to really
facilitating healthy sustainable weight
loss and you know the accomplishments of
fitness goals or performance goals or
the improvement of longevity because
that's what I think I focus on so we
kind of said earlier what am I on
nutritionist or whatever how do I make a
living I gotta take a longevity view
longevity approach to short-term goals
what you go you want to win the World
title yeah we can do that you want to
step on stage yeah we can do that you
just want to get your body back after
pregnancy yeah we can do that you're
coming back from a really bad visit to
the cardiologist yeah we can do that too
along with your cardiologist because I
have a team of registered dietitians who
work for me and facilitate that and act
as liaisons and we build the nutrition
the supplementation that doesn't have
contradictions based upon the doctor's
diagnosis and the prescription medicine
so that's what my team my company does a
lot of people don't know that that part
of the business is much bigger than any
MMA business anyone has ever seen the
MMA stuff that's fun and yeah that was
you know I I did that at the the highest
level for a period of time very much
because it was driven out of passion
because I felt I had a skill that I
could I could help kind of walk these
athletes through this very dangerous
process and I had a skill set to help
them do that as healthy as possible so
that was kind of the goal and it built a
nice little business in in one niche so
the business now is is it is a broad
global content outlet with personalized
program
and online programs and apps and books
and all that stuff but I try and give
most of my information for free that
stuff there you need it but what we're
going to talk about [ __ ] man that's
thousands of dollars and just pro pro
tip right there just take it take and
start now one thing that's been really
controversial last couple years that
you're the expert in I so he did was
weight cutting weight kind of yeah for
sure you know no I have all these like I
I don't know what I'm doing
when it comes to fighting I'm not a
fighter I'm a Coptic you know yeah man
you're a man you're getting there but no
but I think about like how I can't make
weight oh yeah it could be that far off
how a guy you know his system breaks
down you know we've seen yeah three or
four fighters in the last couple years
that their system broke down what was
the kid years ago the first guy I'm
tough I think they kept pulling up into
the sauna
he owns a jujitsu school right up the
corner here and then say no nice guy
yeah nice guy it started with him in the
wetsuit bicycle I get the kid nape he
fell in the steam room but they had to
drag him into the steam room but he
didn't make way the Koscheck was
dragging around okay I remember yeah
yeah yeah
I mean how serious is this [ __ ] it's
deadly it's [ __ ] deadly man that's
that's no [ __ ] it's deadly it's a deadly
sport though right these [ __ ] are
swinging baseball bats at each other's
skulls at a very high level for 15 to 25
minutes these fighters don't [ __ ] around
so to go through so as extreme as they
are in that field they will take their
weight cut to the same extreme also like
they take a lot of their life to the
extreme in certain ways with the weight
cut it's like I'm good bro I'm good draw
suck it down get it off and you know
they don't do what they should do when
we work with athletes we call them
career athletes I don't want one off
athletes I want an athlete we work with
52 weeks out of the year you in season
an off season you are monitored by a
dietitian we are setting goals we are
talking to your team we're making sure
that everybody is accountable and in the
process I don't want an eight-week
training camp or here's some cash can
you get me on weight in three days we
get those offers all the time to I don't
want that
so where did the beginning of this start
I just fell off the lintel it's a year
long you all think you're a year-round
thing so like the the trouble with the
weight cutting is the athletes don't
manage their weight they bring in teams
that are ill-prepared to help the
athlete manage their weight or
experience to adequately oversee a
weight cut and then rehydration a lot of
these teams that come here and the
athletes rely on these teams or their
own internal teams their jiu-jitsu coach
their wrestling coach their mortal coach
to the boxing coach all who have very
good intention to see the athlete do
well and they're gonna give them the old
wives tales of what they did or what
their coach had them do which was
severely flawed it's it's decoration its
deprivation its starvation is
dehydration that's all they do eat less
drink less work more get hotter put that
suit on put the plastics on getting the
[ __ ] you know bathtub you know stay
in the bathtub don't leave the room
duct-tape the [ __ ] door shut turn on
the blow dryers that's what these
[ __ ] are doing that's insane man
that's that's what I talk about with you
know let go too far and on specific
issues but globally that's the problem
so when these athletes are missing
weight if there's a couple reasons some
athletes really try and they're so [ __ ]
they just medically can't do it but
usually it's because they've been doing
it the wrong way they shut their body
down weeks beforehand two weeks before
in ten days beforehand they pulled their
sodium way too soon they're only
drinking distilled water
there's no carbohydrate coming in their
body there's no glucose for them to
operate but they're doing media they're
driving in cars their stress out then
their coaches are having them train once
or twice a day during fight we get high
levels like coach what the [ __ ] this
athlete is coming in on fumes in order
to [ __ ] make weight because you guys
were all [ __ ] for the last 16 weeks
and tightened it up two weeks beforehand
and you're having them [ __ ] go hard
every night door and fight week for what
purpose so you gotta forget how to
[ __ ] fight and that you know that's
you know in an issue and then so that's
going on I saw a fight or main event
fighter and a big big [ __ ] fight not
my fighter but a big dude at like 12
o'clock at night in the gym where I was
done for the day and I was going to get
my work in and before I fell asleep and
I had to be up at 5 o'clock the next
morning I walk in [ __ ] tired they
have this
athlete on the [ __ ] treadmill cutting
weight in plastics with the ramp as high
as it will go
sprinting screaming Adam just like you
know vulgar you know the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you know whatever
- like motivate him if you will yeah
athletes falling can't keep up can't
keep pace
they're cutting weight they're not
working cardio they're cutting weight
this is the night before Lance he goes
out there and he B makes weighting his
gaunt as hell and loses a very very
close fight loses a very close fight had
they not killed him in that type of
workout had they properly brought him in
on weight healthy with his you know
micronutrients intact if you will he
would has probably got a three round
finish because he wouldn't have broken
down as fast so weight cutting the
dangers of weight cutting manifest in
many ways that athlete you could say
took probably 60 extra blows to the head
because he wasn't in the physical shape
because he drew himself down so far down
that he had to go in extra two rounds
with that guy who was punching him in
the face you could have the conversation
on that we kind of look long-term also
so when we work with athletes we want it
to be 52 weeks out of the year but also
our goal when we work with an athlete is
not to win the UFC world title it's to
tell their great grandchildren about
when they won the UFC world title that's
the conversation we have with our
athletes so if you just want to get
across the finish line faster well
that's not it's not what we do you will
get across it faster faster must fat
much faster or we're looking somewhere
else you know we're looking completely
somewhere else what about like really
[ __ ] intelligence ah really because
they keel it the other [ __ ] I'm doing
the other side that I keep hearing is
that sometimes they like they miss
weight on purpose like it's beneficial
to them to lose the person just be a
little heavier how much does that I've
been a part of this I've seen it
firsthand never our athlete because my
athletes are always on weight so we
always have and we knew some athletes in
some teams there's you know you know the
reputation
you're probably gonna make an extra 20
percent because these [ __ ] are gonna
pull up short and one of a lot of
athletes do is they pull up short with
it usually it's within three pounds of
the weight class because they just
[ __ ] usually they're being a dick
the offseason right and then they just
quit during fight week and then they
pull up a little early you know within
three pounds so the fight won't get
called off it's like four and up five
enough the fight might get called off by
the Commission you get it within three
within two that's kind of ideal so you
don't have to go through the last little
bit of hell any athlete will tell you
any fighter will tell you the last two
pounds or the I'd rather cut the first
twenty than the last two a hundred
percent I've cut weight [ __ ] yeah
godless times myself and my own life
I've been in there and in these
situations so lost where I was again
about that no okay so you fight it 1:55
yeah
what do you walk around in the offseason
if you're a 55 athlete well Mirsad
backtick let's use him he fights at 145
he walks around no higher than 172 we
like to keep his weight usually about
164 164 to 168 on you know let's say
we're hitting strength phases three week
strength phase that's probably 12 weeks
before his next fight he we might blow
him up a little bit too high 60s you
know even low 70s but rarely anymore not
for the last two years I like him to be
62 to 64 which he primarily is and then
three weeks out we'll bring him down
into mid 50s or so so he still feels
good
he's not really sacrificing anything yet
we're not pulling the food if you will
and we just rearranged the food intake
so it's not so much a calorie reduction
it's just a restructuring of the
calories that are actually coming in
because we focus on a lot of the
digestibility of the food and most
people don't talk about how is the food
actually digesting so if we have ample
Darr proper digestion efficient
digestion the food acts differently and
most athletes don't digest properly the
timing is issues and I do take issue
with a lot of the the synthetics like
the the powders in the the you know
workout drinks and things like that but
even athletes doing like Gatorade and
powered from that stuff all the way to
like the the concoction solutions
you know Pedialyte sand and things like
that that actually it's it has a lot of
sucralose which which is shown I don't
even know how many times to disrupt
digestion in the digestive environment
so why am I going to
put a synthetic chemical into my my
digestive environment that will [ __ ] up
the operation of the digestive
environment while on that death doorway
and I need to get real [ __ ] food and
nutrients back in me [ __ ] but
down in my gut like the [ __ ]
barbarians are [ __ ] fighting the
English well you know all the [ __ ]
parachute you know droppings of good
healthy stuff is trying to come in it's
just getting chewed up because these
synthetic chemicals and and this is what
frustrates me and because what our
system is most people say adulteresses
shits just so simple he always says the
same basic [ __ ] yeah cuz it [ __ ]
works it works as us we're the only team
with a 100% success ratio over 20 years
we worked with the [ __ ] worse - the
best the Johnny Hendrix the the Tiago
Alvez respectfully when it came to
weight cutting Kelvin Gastelum rampage I
don't even [ __ ] know Vitor the miss
wait multiple times had issues never
with us and that was some of their best
performances from a health standard
whether they fought a beast in front of
them or not from a health perspective
that's that's what we do we don't mean
the [ __ ] help macro thing that's
[ __ ] like 90s if they're still
focused on macros you're [ __ ] 20
years behind but what I've had the
opportunity to do because I've been
doing it such a high level for so long
I'm on the [ __ ] cresting wave
everybody's on the beach like they don't
even know what the [ __ ] I'm doing
they'll take them three years to even
understand what the [ __ ] were doing out
here cuz every week it's new athlete's
new athlete's new athlete's new
athlete's new data you know new input
new technique new food new timing new
this new that oh boom another one high
level athlete a type a Type A - a type
come on now so it's it just through time
if I was a idiot I think we wouldn't we
would have arrived at this point because
this is what works it's just the
scientific method all the way through
what works best what works best what
works best what works best this is what
works best this is it and nobody can
refute it because all they well this
thing does that to like either will
lower your insulin if you don't have
first carbs first thing in the morning
so that means I should eat that
completely for everything forever and
ever and ever and then you can buy my
powder and take my pills and then come
on over here and join my thing
that's what that [ __ ] is that's not one
of what I do it's not what we do so when
we deal with athletes that's the way it
is so when I said the fix right come in
like thick [ __ ] you're not sleeping
enough your [ __ ] train you're
training too much three high-intensity
sessions in 72 [ __ ] hours you crazy
I wonder why you can't sleep go you're
already in overreaching overreaching
syndrome overreaching state you're
already there
like you've body's your [ __ ] wired it
to [ __ ] I don't know wonder now your
punches aren't coming off you look like
[ __ ] in training because you're [ __ ]
nervous system is operating the way it
should and also like you come and come
in and you know massage those areas fix
that areas Speaker Johnny and he's
fighting it right he fought the
bare-knuckle thing how did he do not
good you got knocked out I think in the
first round by Dakota Cochrane who's a
big he's like a tough level kid Ultimate
Fighter no disrespect he's a fighter you
know but he was like a journeyman
conduct at the tough level [ __ ] not
Johnny I look nasty doing it look like a
world beater came out there and [ __ ]
no respect just we ran right through a
lot of Johnny look like and then not
good like he did against GSP man that
was the best that was the best the best
version of Johnny the most mentally
focused he was was getting ready for GSP
when I first started working with Johnny
before the I don't even know the fight
now so when it was a lot of flights it I
think I was with Johnny for seven fights
I said what's your goal he said to be
joy same here okay not to win the
[ __ ] world title just so happened
George had that goal that's all you
wanted to do and why not for the [ __ ]
money just to say that I was better
that's all Johnny wanted to do I'm
[ __ ] he's the best guy in the [ __ ]
world Johnny Hendrix thinks he's better
and on that day I believe that they did
fight I do believe Johnny Hendrix was
better I believe he was better and I
believe he won that fight I believe he
clearly won that fight no disrespect to
the geosphere George got the decision I
think even George knows that he didn't
win that fight you know I believe so and
it's it's not it's just it was a beauty
a beautiful event I think Johnny did
enough to win and after that fight I'd
say yeah he did what he had to do and he
was done he would I believe you know
mentally yeah it happens what do you get
back up for right you did it yeah that's
it no you shot your load yeah it's over
I stuff to come back from that he was so
focused man he said now if he Willoughby
George
it would have been a whole different
other animal you would have made way god
knows how long he would have done well
yeah that's uh yeah that's a mental
block a lot of people have they get to
that certain spot and they they're very
happy in the end wha and that's okay too
that's okay yeah you gotta get out in
the fight game you guys it's not like
you know you're you're running coffee
shops when you mentally at that point
you got to get out where you get knocked
out by Dakota Cochrane in the
bare-knuckle fighting championship
that's not good for your kids right
that's not good for your family or for
your legacy you know that's that's
that's a concern you know and we'll see
we're learning a lot about the
aftershock of the UFC right now yeah
just really good article staying home
posted on Saturday you see that no I
don't think so I was gonna get the fight
I'm gonna read this article and it was
about why Chuck Liddell had a fight
because he had a job at the UFC but they
find when done William Morris bought in
with the money so he had to take that
fight at four years old what the [ __ ]
for financial reasons you need that
money for though like Chuck know this
I'm the numbers guy I'm um you know I
pay attention what did he make in his
career ten mil four mil well okay you
[ __ ] gotta come back and fight for
money and you know it's I'm just being
honest but what the [ __ ] happened to
that money you not living the life you
watch the movie broke the document yeah
get a [ __ ] 401k you guys really have
to you know it comes it goes yeah if you
don't appreciate it but you think it's
never gonna end well money goes fast
when people think they don't live well
for certain in my own less you have
you'll promptly got a fixed income from
it mortgage or whatever but money goes
fast now you know and you how many
trainers in the a but that you know you
got this guy ten ten ten ten
you know you're paying for tens yeah and
you paying taxes you know so when you're
paying for tens and a five for an
attorney that's you know that's a lot of
[ __ ] money yeah you know it's tough
on how big a payday
well what do you have an agent or a
manager yeah I'll have an attorney I got
the [ __ ] I got Dolce yeah I got the
jiu-jitsu coach yeah they all gotta eat
yeah most of them don't know
that's the said that's the sad thing
most of them - they all gotta eat so you
know it's so funny when you we talk
about this all the time that I've seen
it again I've been here for 20 years and
some guys come out here and nothing get
on the TV show you know they were they
were with the John Foley agent okay and
ylim your management and now that about
three are at CAA yeah they got a shkoff
berry and whatever fraternity's you look
at their IMDB and you can't fire people
that they're automatically paint and
that's not counting a 3% to the business
manager and then you sitcom goes off the
air and one day you get a call for your
business man he's like a dog I'm if you
know this sure most solid dough or you
got to start reducing you're that guy
that you taking on the road to do
jumping jacks with he's no bueno no boy
you gotta let him do it you know yeah I
seen comedians do some wild stuff in 20s
that I had a friend that would bring a
trainer on the road he's on ships now
tell me he wishes yeah [ __ ] I think I
know this guy sixty something and we
ships yeah used to bring a trainer with
him on the road really yeah you just
can't go to a gym and the whole gym do I
know a truck would be filled with no no
no a comedian guy would bring a trainer
with it okay like if he was like Johnny
who bar like if he had muscles yeah it
was no reason yeah crazy
yeah pay this guy two grand yeah the
Train really you're gonna train him with
you on the road and he wasn't no Ron
White okay you know at least we're on
whites making seven eight million a year
I could see Rob white bringing a trainer
with him on the road yeah but not this
guy this guy was mediocre and he was
bringing a [ __ ] trainer with him on
the road less young like five years on
the plane and he would sub bitchin I was
headed to Zanies and he was headed to a
ship he was taking a cargo to Galveston
connecting flight because he had no
points left but he made millions
he bought a house up in the mountains
yeah and now you gotta keep up with the
Joneses you know and he wouldn't sound
God knows what the [ __ ] he's doing
you know he used to bring a trainer with
him on the road today I tell you I'm
bringing a trainer with me just smack me
in the face unless it's me
unless it's Mikey yeah they won't be
good [ __ ] right making sure I don't put
that [ __ ] fork down touch that
[ __ ] convert-a-car they'll still
around you see out there
is there one of them I think there is
one there used to be one right on 35 in
Neptune that's where we go that was the
one I think that's gone now Neptune
right Jesus Christ him I'm gonna play
that Neptune
Graham to school bitty basketball 1978
they almost killed us isn't that what
Nicholson is from yeah yep thank you was
very high school right yeah yeah then
who else the quarterback Joe Theismann's
from down there okay the Heisman me a
Bon Jovi of course Bon Jovi
for a Springsteen Bruce you guys got a
lot of [ __ ] man on the show a
lot to come a lot of you know a lot of
your people come and live in that County
in that area you know they've accessed a
45-minute from the city an hour to
Philly 45 to Atlantic City you know
international flights in and out kids
can run the streets with doors open
philia Lord nor I like knowing how far
you know when you live it some I could
be standing in my house in under 60
minutes you know and that's that's like
that's too much that's 45 mile drive
yeah that's why I didn't buy a house um
woman Hills that's why you flying the
burbank right
I find the Burbank on the shorts I find
the Burbank as much as I could yeah you
know in the old days it was a lot more
flights out of Burbank there's a flight
to New York out of my leaves tonight at
10:55 and JetBlue
yeah the Taoiseach two counties on that
flight yeah man and County at 5:00 in
the morning they have a bad flight
that's not a bad one but it's just that
our driver after three days on the road
I just want to get off yeah I just want
to get home I get up in the middle of
night like a burglar at 4:00 in the
morning on a Saturday to get on that
four or five at 9:00 the more time to
deal with it I kill myself on Saturdays
I sleep a little extra yeah I
work out and I [ __ ] sleep like four
hours and this I catch 3-4 hours asleep
I got on the plane I don't sleep on the
plane I drink water the hopeful I have
nothing salty and then I get I do
exercises I move my feet on the plane up
and down because the calf yeah is the
heart of the legs yeah the [ __ ] pump
on the leg so I keep so my ankles don't
get swollen yeah I mean I watch all that
[ __ ] you have to win your trap have to
half the others radiation on the planes
it's where you have to have to drink
water yeah you know and try to drink
alcohol on a plane I get [ __ ] up on a
point I'm smoking a joint on [ __ ]
that thing's not gonna kill no but it's
just gonna slow the [ __ ] minister
yeah so but that's it Mikey belch a it
was a [ __ ] we're just great team I
know man I always lose something
no when I see you where can they find
yet the Dolce DICOM that's it that's it
that's the website that's that's
everything we have you know its own you
know I don't want to be salesy but we've
got within a bunch of [ __ ] there they
can use your code Church and save 10% if
they want to but whatever you know it's
all there and I'm always here I'm
accessible you know I try and be
accessible through Souls no I see you I
see you you do the Q&A I do that on
Instagram because I read a lot and I go
wow you know you know people have know
and I see a lot of people take pictures
for you yeah I see a lot of people you
interact with people which is huge yeah
that's all they want I try them it's
just a little bit of time for somebody
say man you drive yeah you try you drop
two pounds or whatever people no idea
how really tough it is to you know if
it'll eat athletes have a hard time
cutting weight yeah
think of what regular cops you know yeah
it takes a little bit more discipline if
elite athletes have a hard time cutting
weight imagine the American gel yeah
it's it's all habits man it's just you
just establish the habits and people act
like it's it's such a hindrance on their
life to like have to plan their food it
actually frees your life up I got no one
over to eat tomorrow no and I'm gonna
eat all the meals tomorrow so I'll have
to worry about what the [ __ ] am I gonna
eat right now and drive it in my car
what do you want I don't know what do
you what do you feel I don't know what
do you feel like that [ __ ] boom I'm
done I'm fat already I'm already now
steps ahead so and the food you can have
whatever
you want food wise you know you were
saying before we have the the breakfast
ball which is the oats the berries the
peanut butter we have the the chili we
have the fajitas you know and then in
the pastas and and and the steak and
they'll end no leaner meals and the you
know Waldorf salads and all that [ __ ]
it just comes down to the consistency I
don't care really what the [ __ ] you eat
just make sure it's real food and eat it
throughout the day you know about the
same size meal you know four times a day
is it probably a good approach to eating
I worry about fasting you know it's just
eating a good four clean meals per day
and a meal could be an apple and some
cashews where it could be salmon and
asparagus it could be a burger you know
and and some some baked steak fries at
home which will slice the potato throw
it in the oven for 20 minutes and oh we
have french fries here done tastes
better than the [ __ ] you'll [ __ ]
get at most restaurants for fifteen
bucks so again that's that's the take
man that's what we do that's that's the
message why with the Weight Watchers
yesterday
yeah and they're waiting at 286 okay it
was my anniversary December 9th and I
walked in there at 309 my goal was to
get away from 300 uh-huh as much as
possible well I usually do is December I
work harder yeah December's are really
easy one to gain weight yeah and then
you're dead in January I don't do that I
tighten it down and December like I
tighten it down like even in New York
Howie I'll go crazy one day after yeah I
got a Chinese with my friends one night
or whatever but I'll keep it like if I
go either Thai and I won't touch the
bread you know you got to eat the pasta
oh she's you know I won't know I won't
touch the dessert okay I won't touch the
dessert I drink water
I'll do the salad and I'll do something
spaghetti ish but not mean ish yeah and
if they got something fishy if they got
you know cioppino or something like that
I'll always go to the seafood right yeah
I'll always go to the seafood wrap
that's always a win but if I go to a
Cuban restaurant now I've been really
good the last two times yeah Cubans make
great chicken okay that garlic chicken
and then some kind of grill that's
delicious
again with black beans and wet red rice
or black beans or red beans and white
rice now it's basically eight points and
that's
eight points is not [ __ ] bad yeah and
you can eat chicken so I kept 25 bought
for the year my anniversary was just 25
pounds down that's awesome man you
should be proud you gotta remember
that's going on the road yeah that's
[ __ ] you know that's tight and I'm 55
my drink water and I gain weight all
right you know I gotta go to kickboxing
I gotta go to jujitsu tomorrow I lift
you know that's the lift of this [ __ ]
me up a little - yeah the lift is a
little bit heavy keeping the weight on a
little bit yeah I did the lift is good
way then shop me up a couple weeks ago I
went up to like 291 I was like what a
[ __ ] on that barbarian Brandon I asked
how much on my squad she's like I think
last week you [ __ ] at 470 go huh we
gotta [ __ ] you know she does the slow
motion with the stopwatch okay so it's
all ten up down yep and they tried for
two and a half minutes but you could
have you could do three okay and the
last one you gotta hold it at the squat
position then drop it Jesus Christ huh I
know holy body
oh my god all I do is five exercises
okay after that we do a pulldown like
300 pounds she buckles me up and do a
pull down all the way down then after
that I do a bench press then after that
we doing a domino machine with it's up
to here and you have to put your hands I
can go all the way out and I so [ __ ]
it opens up your back really sharp yeah
you're out in 20 minutes
it's a stopwatch workout okay and it
builds cardiovascular I feel better in
jiu-jitsu my breathing has really
improved and jiu-jitsu is this that a
gym does this happen yeah okay
it's called Pagal fitness dance right
that sounds good I like it's a chick and
I knew about the strain I had heard
about it before and I looked into it my
go you know what this is one at 55 is
when I really have to start doing
something yeah a little different so I
do the Muay Thai twice a week if I get
two more ties to jujitsu and two
strengths and yeah that's good that's
good pearl athlete level and I take the
two days off to the rest some weeks I'd
do one Jiu Jitsu and to kick boxing's
yeah some weeks I do - Jiu Jitsu you
know to keep boxing's and the jiu-jitsu
my classic got my boy and I trained for
that RHD down there
when I trained up here on - you know I'm
just trying 95 year old guy with a five
year old I'm not trying to be mr.
America I'm gonna try to do steroids and
then yeah I'm just trying to keep the
weight off to keep the heart healthy and
that's it and that's it it's the name of
the game smoking reefer no nothing else
just reefer no alcohol
yeah and I said Mike adultery I'm just
still in shock that you moved to Jersey
and I'm kind of it's ballsy yeah it's
ballsy that I don't have those balls
right now I wish I could tell you who
had the balls in my heart this times I'm
like I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here I
just don't know where to go
Jersey I don't want to make a mistake so
when we went we weren't gonna go back
we're gonna go somewhere else and then
where were you gonna go
but maybe New Hope Pennsylvania close
enough far enough you know it's a nice
area actually Doylestown yeah some nice
areas up that's a good house yeah good
deal still yeah and you're really two
hours out of this city you're close
enough to the city horses oh yeah you
look like a [ __ ] white birds take the
kids to the beach on the weekend you
know no problem it's a real house so we
were looking there and then we've rented
a house in my hometown for the summer
just like end of August let's go down
there rent to the house like a you know
right where you know we ended up moving
to because we sat there on the front
porch that first night and the breeze
was busy there's kind of a hot humid day
but the coal breeze blew in off the
ocean you could hear the rustling of the
trees in the background and kind of
neighbors soft porch lights you know all
on down this beautiful tree-lined Street
here in the pounding ocean you know on
the sand just you know block and a half
away my wife and I would just sat there
like this is it we gotta we gotta get
back here this is this is no set no stop
[ __ ] around coming back here let's
set a plan that was August of 2017
August of 2018 moved my entire family
packed up our truck sold everything in
Vegas essentially packed up my truck
wife three-year-old daughter
one-year-old daughter
seven year old American Pit Bull Rescue
12 year old Maine [ __ ] cat in the back
of the suburban and we were homeless
because we sold our house August 5th and
we weren't closing on the new house
until August 10th so legitimately we
were
homeless is good which is good I love
this [ __ ] and we're just in the truck
in the truck as I cross the country or
the [ __ ] we want right now yeah you know
and then we had the destination we got
there and it's it's just been awesome
ever since when have you made the move
happy that uh now you inspired me a
little bit in a canal but it's always
good seeing you man whenever you're in
town you're always welcome on the show
if you want to quality whatever you want
brother you know your family it's always
great to see you my brother yes so happy
you [ __ ] made time for us to hell
yeah I missed you man has been too long
and don't forget I got not no day it's
over I got [ __ ] Bakersfield Wednesday
night and then I won't see you
[ __ ] again to like the 27th of
December in Oxnard Level II live I think
the 27th through the 29th or something
so that's it I'm going on vacation we're
shutting down the podcast next week and
everything we're not [ __ ] around so
that's it and that's that
I'll see you [ __ ] Thursday
morning tip-top Magoo I want to thank
Mike Dolce I want to thank the flying
Jew and I want to thank you
[ __ ] for listening it for being
family and if he came to La Jolla last
weekend thank you very much the shows
were [ __ ] sensational all right I want
to thank my main man Mike Dolce for
stopping by today but most importantly I
want to thank you guys but real quickly
do not forget now to December 25th
23andme DNA kits are on sale 23andme
helps you understand what your DNA can
tell you about your family and your
family's story the 23andme DNA kit is
the perfect gift for everyone you love
there's never been a better way to give
the gift of genetic discovery to your
parents your siblings your answer your
grandparents anyone else on your list
it's the one gift you can buy the entire
family that will be unique for each
loved one 23andme health and ancestry
service includes 90 plus personalized
genetic reports that offer DNA insights
on what makes you unique learn how your
genes play a role when your well-being
and lifestyle choices learn how your
arms and legs twitch while you're
sleeping with 23andme sleep movement
report you can discover how your
genetics may be influenced how much you
move your arms and legs during your
sleep
knew about the digit near that I the
ability to match musical pitch mosquito
Brite frequency some people may fear
that they get more mosquito bites and
people around them so what makes some
people more attractive the mosquito than
others genetics may be partly to blame
but listen let's cut them to the chase
right now go to 23andme coms last Church
and I'm gonna get you 30% off that
23andme kit order your DNA kit at
23andme dot-com slash Church that's
23andme dot-com slash Church I also want
to welcome to the podcast one of my
favorites hims let me tell you something
you're losing your hair you having
problems with you know last I mean gets
thick listen these are all things that
could be taken care of it's not to be
embarrassed about the solution is for
hims calm a one-stop shop for hair loss
skin care excuse me and sexual wellness
for men him connects you with real
doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss well-known generic
equivalents the name brand prescription
to help you keep your hair this is no
snake pills or gas station counter
supplements prescription solutions
backed by science no waiting room
no awkward person doctor visits save
hours by going to forums calm it's easy
you answer a few questions
the doctor will review it and can
prescribe you products are shipped
directly to your door let's say you want
on a date and you want to make sure
you're running an off selling this for
him has got you they got your erectile
dysfunction whether you're losing your
hand for hims will change your life if
you're a man go to for him is calm right
now the church family gets hymns for
five dollars for a month while supplies
last see the website for the full
details this would cost hundreds if you
went to a doctor or pharmacy go to four
hymns calm slash Church slash Joey what
am I talking about slash church last
Joey that's four hymns calm slash Joey
again that's for hymns calm slash Joey
listen stop
in your hand stop being embarrassed
about your problems for hims got you
again for the cheap seats for hims calm
/ Joey again I want to thank my man
Magdalene Mike Dolce I want to thank the
[ __ ]
I want to thank kishi for stopping by
and I want to thank new [ __ ]
for being part of the church family like
I said earlier if you came to a Holiness
we can thank you very much for the great
shows and that's it and that's that I'll
see you Thursday morning [ __ ]
ready to rock have a great day
stay black uncle Joey loves you kick
that mule II